for the first time the inquiry into the
diesel gate emissions fixing scandal
heard from the firm in the dock
Volkswagen an inquiry committee was set
up to look into failings to legislate
for real-world tests and police existing
ones also what the EU nu of vw's
infamous defeat devices but in one's own
Henton licked his toe on foreign soil
dammit home to gain on stuff you're to
zone that so it was Nevada pass here the
ambush Lawson does emissions test in on
some concern confidence at /x town
Hoonah Peggy goober proof club also
their French giant Renault which
explained the likely impact on Europe's
car industry rather than incremental nas
costas importantes del dsl y por tanto
para ciertos a mentos Dave I gloss bar a
decir la la trata vida y naturalmente ba
Prabhakar que buscan solutions
alternativas so far the committee has
focused on technical automotive details
and just approved a Midway report
reflecting that many MEP is now hopes
I'll start hitting the political issues
car manufacturers are trying to frame
that it is a problem with the
legislation instead of that they just
should have clean up their car and I
think that argument is becoming more and
more important to what extent have they
been influencing the lawmakers other
manufacturers and former commissioners
will also be called to give evidence
before the committee presents its final
report by the end of the year